I want to pick up in March the 16th, 1902, that we should seek God for himself alone,
or as St. Risa of Avila said, God alone, suffice it. O, how hard it is to have him come
just for a little Louisa said, it's a continuous heartbreak. So this is her incredible love
that can't tolerate not having the Lord with her. Then he made himself seen for a little
in a pitiful state with one arm severed and all afflicted he told me, my daughter, see
what creatures do to me. How can you want me not to chastise them? And while saying this,
he seemed to take a tall cross, the arms of which were hanging over six or seven cities,
and various chastisement would car in these cities. On seeing this Louisa said, I suffered
very much, and he wanting to distract me from that, added my daughter, you suffer very much,
and I deprive you when I deprive you of my presence. This must happen, he said, by necessity,
because since you have been so close to the divinity for a long time, identified with
it as though through its contact, you've enjoyed, as you pleased, all the pleasure of
the divine light. In other words, Jesus is telling Louisa how incredibly privileged
she has been. And of course, each contact with the divinity makes us long for the Lord
more than before. And you reach the point, as she says, of not being able to do without
the Lord. And the more one has enjoyed the light, Jesus says, the more he feels the privation
of that light, and the bothers and the annoyances and the pains which darkness brings with itself.
So if you get the privileges, then you suffer when the privileges appear to be removed from
you, at least for a short time. And then he repeated, however, the most important thing
for everyone is that each thought, each word and each work in everything, we should only
seek the Lord and not seek his own comfort. So that's 2 Corinthians 10, 5, that every
thought should be captured and given to Christ. You should not seek the pleasure of somebody
else, but only the pleasure of God alone. In other words, we must be completely pure in
our seeking of God. We seek him alone. So that's John 544 and Matthew 23 and Deuteronomy
6, 4 to 10. So March 18, 1902, restlessness makes Jesus suffer. This morning, Louisa
said, I felt restless because of the absence of my adorable Jesus. So having received communion,
as soon as he came into my heart, I began to speak much nonsense. My sweet good, she said,
it's not for me to remain calm when you do not come. In seeing me calm, you take advantage,
and you do not give a thought to coming. And so it's necessary to take some steps. Otherwise,
one cannot manage, she said, on hearing me, Jesus moved in my interior. That's Luke 17 21,
the kingdom of God is within you. And he made himself seen in the act of smiling, for he
had heard, and actually enough, and he told me, you then want me to suffer. In fact, knowing
that you are restless, I suffer more. And not trying to be calm is the same as wanting
me to suffer more. And I, insane as I was, Louisa said, said, it's better that you suffer
because from your very suffering, you have more compassion for mine. Besides the suffering
that comes to you from sin, that one is ugly. It's enough that it's not that. And Jesus
said, but if I come, you force me not to chastise when chastisements are so very necessary.
In that case, then you would have to conform to me in wanting what I want. In other words,
conform to divine justice. And Louisa said, remembering that I, what I had seen in the
past days, I said, what chastisements? Do you want to make people die? Well, let them
die. They must come to you and to their fatherland anyway, as long as you save them. What I want
is that you free them from contagious diseases. And there were a lot of really serious contagious
diseases at the beginning of the 20th century. But Jesus didn't pay attention to me, she
said, he disappeared. And as he came back, he made himself seen always with his back
to the world. That means that he is in fury with them because his justice needs to express
itself. And as much as I tried, Louisa said, I could not manage to have him look at it.
And when I wanted to induce him by force, he said, do not force me. Now that inducement
by force is Matthew 11 12, the kingdom of God suffers violence and the valiant take it
by force. He said, do not force me. Otherwise you force me to deprive you of my presence.
So I was left with a remorse, Louisa said, and I felt I have committed many defects and
notice not sins because you can't be in the divine will and sin. So March the 19th, 1902.
Human beings have corrupted themselves of their own volition. I continue to have remorse, Louisa
said. And yet the Lord kept coming and wanting to repair for what I had done the day before,
I told him, Lord, let's go and see what human beings are up to. They are your images. You
know, that's Genesis 127 and Romans 829. Don't you want to have compassion on them? And
he said, no, I don't want to go. They have corrupted themselves of their own free will.
And I will permit that what serves as their nourishment will serve them as infection. In
other words, what they think is something really good for them will have the opposite
effect. Do you want to go to help or comfort or do something will go ahead? Jesus said,
I won't. So I left my beloved Jesus and I went into the midst of people. I helped someone
to die well. And then I saw where the infected air was coming from and did various penances
in order to move it away. And then I came back. Blessed Jesus continues to let himself be
seen, but in silence. Okay. So as far as Jesus is concerned, the chastisements are so absolutely
essential that they must happen. So March the 23rd, 1902, the support of true sanctity
is the knowledge of self. But the scripture tells us that the knowledge of self is the
beginning of wisdom. So after I struggled very much, my most sweet Jesus came and he
told me, my daughter, the support of true sanctity is the knowledge of self. And Louisa
said, really? He said, certainly, because with the knowledge of self, one undoes himself.
And leans completely on the knowledge that she requires of God. As Proverbs three five,
my son do not lean on your own understanding, lean on God. So what Jesus is saying here
is that when you really get to know yourself and the motivations that you have for doing
things, that will help you to turn away from all the that's wrong and turn truly to God.
So Jesus said, the knowledge of self with the knowledge of self one undoes himself and
leans completely on the knowledge he acquires of God. In such a way that is operating is
the very divine operating since nothing is left of his own being. So here we have to deny
the self its rule and allow God to rule in us. And it's our knowledge of God and our
knowledge of self which go together that enable us to do this. And then Jesus added, when one's
interior imbues and occupies itself with God alone and with all that belongs to him, then
God communicates all of himself to the soul. Now notice that we have to occupy ourselves
completely with him in order to enable him to come and give himself completely to us.
In other words, we have to open up. When her interior then occupies itself now with God
and then with other things, God communicates himself only in part. So the decision is entirely
ours as to how much the Lord actually comes to us because we have to open up, we have
to give him the space to work. So March the 27th in 1902, this is teaching about justice.
Seeing myself outside of myself, I went in search of my most sweet Jesus. And while going
around I saw him in the arms of blessed mother. Tired as I was all daring, I almost snatched
him and I took him in my arms telling him my love is this your promise that you would
not leave me when in the past days you barely come if at all. And Jesus said my daughter
I was with you, only you have not seen me with clarity. Had your desires been so ardent
as to burn the veil that prevented you from seeing me, you would certainly have seen me.
Now this is something Jesus has been telling her now over the past month or two in these
writings that if her love for him was greater and more powerful, she could actually burn
those veils that are separating them and see him. In other words, she keeps blaming him
and he tells us that there's a little bit of horror in it as well. Then as though wanting
to give me an exhortation, Jesus added, you must not only be upright but just.
The justice enters loving me, praising me, glorifying me, thanking me, blessing me, repairing
me, adoring me, not only for yourself but for all souls past, present and future. In other
words that we have an obligation to adore, praise, bless, honor, worship and honor and
praise the Lord. These are the rights of justice, he said, which I demand from each soul and
which are due to me as creator. So that's John 1-3, Colossians 1-16, Ephesians 3-9,
Revelation 4-11. This is simply why we owe him. And one who denies me even one of these
rights Jesus said can never be called just. Therefore think about fulfilling your duty
of justice. For in justice you will find the beginning, the means and the end of sanctity.
So Louisa is being told very nicely, stop thinking about your own loss and all the rest
of it and start thinking about glorifying and praising God in your loss or in your gain,
in your darkness, in your light, in your aridity, in your prayer, in everything that we're to
praise and glorify God. So, March the 30th 1902, the garment of light of the risen humanity
of Jesus. So this morning finding myself outside of myself for a little while I saw my adorable
Jesus in the act of the resurrection, Louisa says. He was all clothed with refulgent light
that Sam 1-0-4 verse 2, "O Lord how great you are, you are clothed in majesty, you are
wrapped in a robe of light." So they saw him like this on Mount Tabor and this is what
he was like in the resurrection as well. So he was all clothed with refulgent light so
much so that the sun remained obscured before that light of his. I was enchanted and I said
"Lord, if I am not worthy to touch your glorified humanity, let me at least touch your garments."
And he told me, "My beloved, what are you saying?" After I rose again I had no need
for material garments, rather my garments are of the most pure light. And this is what
covers my humanity and these garments of light will shine eternally. So that's Hebrews 1-3.
He is the radiant light of God's glory and the perfect copy of his nature. He is light.
Does John 1-4 as well? So these garments of most pure light will shine eternally because
they're completely spiritual, giving unspeakable joy to all the senses of the blessed in heaven.
This has been conceded to my humanity because there was no part of it which was not covered
with the pro-brium, pains and wounds. That's Romans 8-18 that the sufferings of this life
cannot even be compared to the glory that will be revealed to us. And also Philippians
2 verses 6-11 that he humbled himself to be tortured and gave his life in the passion
and then he was glorified. So having said this, Jesus disappeared and I find neither
his humanity nor his garments, or rather I would take his sacred garments between my
hands and they would escape me. That's a bit like a child trying to grab a handful of air
or to grab a bit of sunlight in their hands. It's not an hour dimension so there's no
possibility of doing it. So April the 4th, 1902. By destroying moral goods, physical
and temporal goods are also destroyed and this is what governments need to be warned
about today. Continue in my usual state my adorable Jesus keeps coming but almost always
in silence, it's chastisement time. And rather he says to me something pertaining
to truth but it happens that as long as the Lord is present I understand it and I seem
to be able to repeat it. But when he disappears I feel the light of truth which has been infused
in me being withdrawn and I am unable to repeat anything. Now Sam 36 verse 9, "Lord, in your
light we see light." When he withdraws his light, his interior light from us, we don't
see anything, we're just completely blind. So one Corinthians 2, 9, we're not able to
express this at all. This morning then I had to struggle very much in waiting for him and
as he came he transported me outside of myself showing himself to be very indignant. So in
order to placate him I made various acts of repentance but Jesus didn't seem to like
any of them. I would do my utmost in varying the acts of repentance, who knows he might
like them but in the end I said to him, "Lord, this is a very important prayer. I repent
of the offenses given by me and by all souls past, present and future of the earth. And
I repent and I am sorry for the sole reason that we have offended you our highest good
who deserve love but we have dared to give you offenses. It was this prayer that made
him pleased and appeased." That's a very good prayer to say at confession time.
After this Jesus transported me into the middle of a road where there were two men in the
shape of beasts, all intent on destroying every kind of moral good. Now the description
we're getting here sounds awfully like Lenin and Marx or people of that ilk at that time.
They seem to be strong like lions and drunken with passion. At the mere sight of them they
struck terror and fright. Blessed Jesus told me, "If you want to placate me a little bit
go and pass through these men to convince them of the evil that they are doing facing
their fury." Because it was people like Marx and Lenin who wanted to destroy all moral
good, to destroy religion, to destroy truth and to put their own version of hell upon
the earth, which they did. As soon as they saw me, Louisa said, they wanted to swallow
me, but I said to them, "Let me speak and then you can do with me whatever you want.
You must know that if you reach your intent of destroying every moral good pertaining
to religion, virtue, dependency and social welfare, without realizing your mistake you
could also destroy all corporal and temporal goods," which they did. They left the Soviet
Union in the most dreadful state. In fact, as much as is taken away from moral goods,
not much are physical evils doubled. In other words, the more you take away moral goods,
the more even physical goods are absolutely destroyed. So without realizing it, you go
against yourselves, destroying all those fleeting and passing goods that you so much love. Not
only this, but you're looking for those who will destroy your own very lives. And you
will cause the survivors among you to shed bitter tears. And then Louisa said, "I made
a most great act of humility," which I am not even able to repeat. And they remained
like someone who recovers from a state of madness. And also they were so weak that they
did not have the strength even to touch me. So I passed through them freely and I understood
that there is no power that can resist the power of reason and the power of humility.
This is all happening on a spiritual plane. It couldn't happen on a physical plane. April
the 16th, 1902, "How to deal with passions and spiritual victory lies in repressing the
first motions." Now, I want you to put a VIP on this one, because in volumes one to
four, we're getting the foundations of how to live a life of union with God in the divine
will. And therefore we have to deal with the ego, we have to deal with passions and so
on. Because if you're still trying to deal with that and trying to live in divine will
later on, it doesn't work. You have to deal with this first. This morning, my adorable
Jesus was not coming. So not seeing him come, I said, "What am I doing in this state? If
the object that held me captured does not come anymore." It is better if I finish it
once and for all. So Louisa is back to the usual point that if she's not actually in
ecstasy, if she's not actually suffering the passion, then she thinks she should get up
and live a normal life. It's her perennial temptation. She's been told endlessly that
that's not what the Lord wants. As I was saying this, my sweet Jesus came for just a
little and he said, "Daughter, everything is in repressing the first motions." This is
terribly important. If we are to overcome any interior enemy, it's the first movement.
If the soul is attentive to this, everything will go well. But if she is not at the first
motions which are not repressed, passions will come out and break the divine fortress
which surrounds the soul. Okay. Passions will come out and break the divine fortress which
surrounds the soul like a hedge in order to keep her well guarded and to move away from
her the enemies which always try to lay traps for her and to harm the poor soul. However,
if as soon as she perceives it, she enters into herself. That's number one. Number two
humiliates herself. Number three repents and number four remedies it with courage, then
the divine fortress closes again around the soul. If on the other hand she does not remediate,
the divine fortress broken as it is will let all vices rush in. Therefore, if you want
the fortress not to leave you alone even for one instant, be attentive to the first motions,
the first thoughts and the first words which are not upright and holy because once the
first ones have escaped you, it's no longer the soul that reigns, but rather the passions.
Now let me just illustrate this for a moment and it's this. Supposing something happens
and I want to get angry about it. Now, if I get angry, whatever I do with my tongue is
not going to be right, the thoughts in my mind are not going to be right, the feelings
in my body are not going to be right. So if I want to stem that anger, I've got to take
hold of it in its very first movement. And if we conquer the anger in its very first
movement, nobody will ever suffer from my words or my actions because the anger was
not allowed its expression. And it's this conquering of ourselves that the Lord actually
wants. We can't conquer anybody else, but it is important for us to conquer ourselves.
And as St. Paul says in Romans, oh, what is it now, 517? I think it is that we would
reign in life with Christ and we can only reign in life when we conquer ourselves. Okay. So
April the 25th, 1902, the cross is a sacrament and this is also a very important message.
This morning I found myself outside of myself and after going in search of my sweet Jesus,
I found him, but in such a pitiful state as to break my heart. He had his hands wounded
contracted because of the sharpness of the pain to the point that they couldn't be touched.
I tried to touch them in order to extend his fingers and heal his wounds, but I couldn't
because Blessed Jesus was crying for that very strong pain. And then not knowing what
to do, I squeezed him to myself. And I said to him, my loving good, it has been a while
since you shared with me the pains of your wounds, maybe this is why they are so embittered.
I pray you to let me share in your pains so that as I suffer them, your sufferings may
be less. So Louisa is choosing the cross, which is typical of the victim soul. As I
was saying this, Louisa said, an angel came with a nail in his hand and he pierced my
hands and feet through. As he was driving the nail into my hands, the fingers of my dear
Jesus loosened up and his wounds were healed. And while I was suffering, he told me my daughter,
the cross is a sacrament. Each one of the sacraments contains its special effect. One
removes sin, another one confers grace, another one unites one with God, another one gives
strength and many other effects. But the cross alone unites all these effects together,
producing them in the soul with such effectiveness as to render her in a very short time, similar
to the original from which she came. So that's Philippians 3.10 that we become like Jesus.
Many people claim to follow Jesus, but they're not all that interested in becoming like him
in his pains and sufferings. Some people like Saint Paul were very generous this way. So
April the 29th, 1902 is another very important message. One who wants everything from God
must give all of himself to God. This morning my adorable Jesus came for a little telling
me my daughter. One who wants everything from God must give all of himself to God. So this
is the marvelous exchange that must actually happen. And he stopped without telling me anything
else for the time being. Seeing him close to me, Louisa said, I said, Lord, have compassion
on me. Don't you see that everything is dry and withered in me understood? It seems to
me that I have become so dry that if I had as if I had never received a drop of rain,
he said so much the better. Don't you know that the drier the wood is, the more easily
the fire devours it and converts it into fire. To Corinthians 12 line, my power works best
in weakness. One spark alone is enough to ignite it. But if it is full of humours like
the sap in the plants and not well dried, it takes a big fire to ignite it. And much
time to convert it into fire. It's the same for the soul. When everything is dry, one spark
alone is enough to convert or completely into fire, the fire of divine love. So Louisa
said, Lord, you're making fun of me. How ugly then everything is. And besides, what do you
have to burn if everything is dry? And he said, I'm not making fun of you. You yourself
cannot understand that when not everything is dry in the soul, complacency is a humour,
of satisfaction is a humour. One's own taste is a humour, self esteem is a humour. Oh dear,
all these things that we have to absolutely, deliberately and creatively get rid of will
come back. So this is why the Lord has to allow us to experience erudity in prayer and seeming
absolute. How would I put it? Like a plant that has no fruitfulness all dried up? He's
got to allow it to happen so that he can set the fire of divine love really working in
us. So on the other hand, when everything is dry, the soul operates these humours, sorry,
when everything is dry and the soul operates or works, she continues working. These humours
have no place in which to arise. And then the divine fire, finding only the soul naked,
that's the bit you see we don't like. We don't like this awful sense of our complete naked
nothingness. But when the soul is naked, as dry as she was created by the divine fire,
with no other extraneous humours, there's something that belongs to the divine will.
Sorry. Since it is something that belongs to the divine will, it is extremely easy for
the divine will to convert it into its own divine fire. And after this, I infuse in her
the garment of peace. That's really fantastic. Now Jesus is the prince of peace and Philippians
four, seven tells us that this peace passes all understanding and guards the heart and
the mind in Christ Jesus. Isaiah 26 verse three says, Lord, you keep them in perfect
peace whose mind is stayed on you. I infuse into her a garment of peace, he said. And this
piece is preserved by interior obedience. Oh, well, that's something we really need to
look at. Some people think that the external obedience is enough and he says no, no, no,
no, it's the internal submission of the soul to God that's actually desperately important.
And because of this internal submission to God that the soul externally does what God
wants. This piece gives birth to the whole of God within the soul. That is to all the
works, the virtues and the ways of the incarnate word in such a way that one can see in her
his simplicity, his humility, and the dependence of his infantile life, the perfection of his
adult virtues, the mortification and crucifixion of his dying. And so that's Romans 829 that
we become like him transformed into his image. But it always begins from this that one who
wants the whole of Christ must give everything to Christ. So again, I remind you of that
statement of Padre Pio that he said, I deny him nothing and he denies me nothing. So made
the 161902 two sublime states. This morning after I struggled very much, my most sweet
Jesus came and as soon as I saw him, I clashed him tightly to myself. I said to him, my dear
good, this time I will clasp you so much as not to let you escape anymore. That's Song
of Songs 5.6. At that moment, I felt myself completely filled with God. It's like a sponge
being completely filled with water. As if I were inundated in such a way that the powers
of my soul, which are the intellect, memory, and will, remained as though chained and in
operative, they just watched. After I remained in this inoperative yet sweet and pleasant
position for some time, my adorable Jesus told me, my daughter, sometimes I fill the
soul with myself so much that dissolving in me, the soul remains as though idle, that
Sam 1-3-1. Other times I leave a few parts empty within her and then the soul, before
my presence, traffics in an admirable way, bursting into acts of praise, thanksgiving,
love, reparation, and the like in such a way as to fill these voice which I leave in her.
However, these two states are both sublime and they hold each other's hands. In other
words, they're just two aspects of the same mystery. So, whether he takes over completely
or he leaves a little bit for us to do. So, May 22, 1902, the most holy virgin encourages
Jesus to make Louisa suffer. Now, one of the things I love in these writings is the image
of the Blessed Mother. I've always hated that plaster cast image that we have of her
in our statues as if she wasn't a real person with real feelings and real convictions. But
in these writings, you see her as the mother of the human race and the mother of souls
and desperately wanting to save as many as possible. So, she's quite strong in her responses
to both Jesus and Louisa because Jesus is the Savior and Louisa is the one who must
intervene to help at this particular moment to save as much as possible.
As I was in my usual state, Blessed Jesus was not coming. "All how much I had to suffer
and how much nonsense I spoke," she said. "It's useless to say it. Then after I tired
myself well, I felt somebody near me, but I couldn't see his face. I stretched out my
hand to find him and I found him faint with his head leaning on my shoulder. I looked
at him and then recognized my sweet Jesus. It seemed to me that he had fainted because
of all the stuff that I was saying. Then as soon as I saw him come round, I don't know
how much more nonsense I wanted to tell him, but Jesus said to me, "Keep quiet, keep quiet.
Don't say anything else otherwise you'll cause me to faint. Your silence will make me
gain vigor," he said. "And so I will at least be able to kiss you and embrace you and make
you content." So Louisa remained in silence and they kissed each other many times and
Jesus made many shows of love. Now one of the things you have to keep remembering about
Louisa is that she's Italian. Italians keep talking, but there's nothing like a kiss
for shutting you up. You have to stop. So when Louisa says I spoke much nonsense, she's
talking about all the acts of love and everything that she's pouring out in order to try and
draw him back. So that's seen there about him fainting and everything. That's all song
of songs material. After this Louisa said, "I found myself outside of myself and I kept
looking for the beloved of my soul. Not finding him I raised my eyes to the heavens. Who knows
I might find him again." And I saw the Queen Mother and Jesus Christ with his back to
her. In other words, she's now pleading for leniency for the earth and he doesn't want
that either. They were contending with each other. I don't think that's our image of
Jesus and Mary, is it? That she's trying to get him to do something and he's giving
his back to her. He didn't want to listen to his mother and this is why he was giving
her his back all full of fury. And it seemed that the fire of his indignation was coming
out of his mouth. I only understood that on that day our Lord wanted to destroy everything
that served as nourishment for man with the fire of his indignation. But our most holy
virgin did not want it. And Jesus was saying, "But on whom shall I give vent to this burning
fire of my indignation?" And our blessed mother said, "But there is someone on whom
you can give vent to it." And she was pointing to Louisa. Don't you see how she is always
ready for our volitions? On hearing this, Jesus turned to his mother as if they had agreed
together. They called the angels, giving to each of them a spark of that fire which was
coming out of Jesus. And the angels brought them to me, placing one in my mouth and the
others in my hands, on my feet and in my heart, on my heart. I suffered. I felt myself being
devoured and bittered by that fire, but I felt resigned and suffered everything. I just want
to remind you of Isaiah chapter 6, verses 1 to 10, where on seeing the Lord in the sanctuary,
an angel did take one of the colds from God's fire and touched Isaiah's lips and cleansed him
and turned him into the messenger of God. So blessed Jesus and his holy mother were spectators of my
sufferings. And Jesus seemed to be somehow pacified. At that moment, I found myself inside of myself
and the confessor was about to call me to obedience, as usual, when all of a sudden, instead of calling
me to obedience, he placed the intention of having me suffer the crucifixion. So he gets some kind
of an inspiration at the last second and he asks the Lord to give her the crucifixion. Jesus
concurred by sharing his pains with me. It seemed that the confessor completed the work that was
started by our blessed mother. So here you have heaven and earth in agreement. You have the church
on earth and you have blessed mother in heaven, all fighting for the souls that are on earth.
So June the second 1902, the throne of Jesus is composed of virtues that's moral excellence
in every form. The soul who possesses virtues makes Jesus rain in her heart.
This morning after I struggled very much, blessed Jesus moved in my interior and I saw that he was
inside of me as though embraced and sustained by somebody else. I was surprised at seeing this
and he told me, my daughter, the interior of the soul is a filling of passions. And as the soul
keeps knocking the passions down, so does each virtue take its place, accompanied by degrees of
grace according to how the virtue keeps on being perfected. So does grace administers its degrees
to it. So she's seeing a virtue as a person sustaining her inside. And Jesus is saying that
the amount of grace you receive corresponds to the amount of work that you're doing to let that
virtue develop. And since he said, my throne is composed of virtues, that the soul who possesses
virtues provides me with arms and with the throne to be able to reign in her heart. Keeping me
continuously embraced and courted until I delight with her. However, the soul can stain herself
while the virtue remains always intact. So as long as the soul knows how to keep it,
the virtue remains with her. But when she doesn't know, the virtue returns to me to the place from
which it came. Therefore, don't be surprised if you saw me like this in your interior. So all
virtues come from him. His very throne is composed of virtues. As we cooperate in putting the self
in its place and putting all the passions in their place, then the virtues can take over.
And the greatness of the virtue depends on the greatness of our response to the Lord.
So, June the 15th, 1902, or before I go on to that, what we're being told here is that we must
allow the throne of God to be placed in our hearts, just as the throne of the Lord was in the holy
of holies on the ark of the covenant. Now the ark of the covenant had the word of God inside of
it, and we have to have the word of God inside of us as well, so that we actually form the throne
of God on earth so that he can reign among us. This is very important for us as we go on
in understanding that the Lord wants to return to the earth and to reign in us and through us
among souls. So, June the 15th, 1902, this is a very important message. It's all about love.
As I keep repeating to you, the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will and love.
Love is not an attribute of God, it's his very nature.
As I was in my usual state, Louisa said, "My adorable Jesus transported me outside of myself
and told me. My daughter, all virtues can be said to me my qualities and my attributes,
but love cannot be called an attribute of mine, it is in fact my very nature." So, all virtues form
my throne and my qualities, but love forms my very self. That's one John 4, 7 to 17, because God is love.
On hearing this, Louisa said, "I remembered that the day before I had told a person who feared
about the uncertainty of salvation, that one who truly loves Jesus Christ can be sure of being saved.
To me, I believe it's impossible that our Lord would move away from himself, a soul who loves him
with all her heart. Therefore, let us think of loving him and we will have our salvation in hand.
As Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10, where the scripture says, "Hero Israel, the Lord your God is one Lord,
and you shall love the Lord your God with all your heart, with all your soul, with all your mind,
and with all your being." So, if someone loves God with their whole self, it's impossible that
God who is love would repudiate them. So, Louisa said, "I asked Jesus whether by saying this I had
spoken correctly." And he said, "My beloved, you said that with reason, because love has this of
its own self, it forms one object out of two, one will out of two. So, the soul who loves me forms
one single unit with me, one single will. So, how could you be separated from me? More so,
since my nature is love, and wherever it finds a few sparks of love in the human nature,
immediately it unites them to the eternal love." As John 14, 20, and 21, John 15, 9, okay.
"Therefore, just as it is impossible to form two souls out of one soul, or two bodies out of one
body, so it is impossible for one who truly loves me to be eternally lost." Isn't that fantastic?
June 17, 1902, "Mortification produces glory." This is a very short message.
"This morning I saw my beloved Jesus for just a little, and he seemed to be holding a written paper
in his hands on which one could read. Mortification produces glory. One who wants to find the fountain
of all pleasures, which is Psalm 36 verses 9 to 10, one must move away from all that may
displease the Lord." So, this is just a reminder of what we've been told over and over again since
Volume 1, that if we want God, you've got to make room for him and get rid of everything else.
So, June 29, 1902, Jesus speaks about France, the eldest author of the church. King Clovis was
baptized in the year 400, and with his baptism all France became Catholic, and the first of the
European nations to completely enter the church. This morning I saw my adorable Jesus for just a
little, and I don't know why, I heard him say, "Poor France, poor France, you have raised up,
and you have broken and split the most sacred laws, denying me as your God." Now, when you go back
to 1789, the French Revolution, that was when France absolutely expelled God from its nation,
and it did a terrible thing, which was to put a naked woman on the altar of Notre Dame in Paris
and offered her to the God of reason, and they've been completely unreasonable ever since.
So, you have broken and split the most sacred laws denying me as your God. You've made of
yourself an example for other nations to draw them towards evil. Now, France is responsible for
spreading atheistic materialism to all of Europe and therefore to the rest of the world,
and she's responsible for creating secularism as well, and both of these are the foundations
for communism at all that went with it. So, here you have the eldest daughter of the church,
creating the tsunami of sorrow that was going to destroy the 20th century.
So, you've made of yourself an example for other nations to draw them towards evil,
and your example is so much power that other nations are about to be ruined.
Know, however, that as chastisement for this, you will be conquered, and to see that fulfilled,
all you have to do is remember World War I and World War II.
After this, Jesus withdrew into my interior, and I heard him ask for help and pity and compassion
in his many pains. Oh, it was harrowing to hear Blessed Jesus ask for help from his own creatures.
So, July the first 1902, true victims must expose themselves to the pains of Jesus.
As I was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself kneeling at an altar together with two
more people. These are two other victim souls. In the meantime, Jesus appeared over the altar,
and he said, "True victim souls must have communication with my very life. They must avail
themselves of my very self. They must expose themselves to my very pains." While saying this,
he took a pix in his hands and gave communion to all three of us. Now, the other two are not
actually named. There were quite a number of victim souls in the church in the 20th century.
Around this time, you have Three's Newman, probably a little bit later, Alex Andrina,
probably a little bit later, Martha Roba as well, just to name some that has come to my head.
While saying this, he took a pix and gave communion to all three. After this, behind that altar,
there seemed to be a door which led into a street filled with people and jam packed with demons.
In such a way that one could not walk without being squeezed by them. When she says squeezed,
I think you mean crushed. And since it was full of thorns, extremely sharp, one could not make a
movement without feeling one's flesh being pricked deep inside. At any cost, I would have wanted to
escape those diabolical furies. And I almost tried to do it, but someone I don't know who
prevented me by saying to me, "Everything you see are machinations against the church and against
the pope." Now, these are all the plots of the Freemasons and the Communists and the Marxists
and all the rest, because these machinations is going to be the infiltration of the church,
which they successfully did, and were still suffering from the results of that infiltration
of the seminaries, where they put atheists into the seminaries and paid them to persevere in the
seminaries and become priests. And they introduced homosexuality into the priesthood and they brought
devastation into the church. So everything you see, Jesus said, "imaginations against the church
and against the pope." They would want the pope to get out of Rome. Now, that pope is Leo XIII
by invading the Vatican and seizing it. And if you want to avoid these brothers, men and demons
will acquire strength and make these thorns come out, which will prick the church bitterly.
In other words, if you, as a victim soul, refuse to accept these thorns and pricks,
then the church will suffer in a much, much greater way. But if you content yourself
with suffering them, both the one and the other will be weakened. That's Proverbs 6-23.
On hearing this, I stopped, but who can say what I went through and suffered?
I thought I would never again get out from the midst of those diabolical spirits.
However, after staying there almost an entire night, divine protection freed me, that was quite
a long trial for her. So July the 3rd, 1902, Jesus speaks about his eucharistic life.
Continuing in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself inside a church. And since I could not
find my adorable Jesus, I went to knock at a tabernacle to have him open for me.
Since he would not open, made brave, I myself opened it and I found my soul and only good.
Who can say my contentment? I remained as though ecstatic in looking at an unspeakable beauty.
On seeing me, Jesus flung himself into my arms and told me my daughter. Each period of my life
receives from the human race distinct and special acts and degrees of imitation, love,
reparation and other things. But the period of my eucharistic life is all about hiddenness,
transformation and continuous consummation. So much so that I can say that after my love
reached the excess and was even consumed in my infinite wisdom, I could not find any other external
sign to prove my love for them. This is awfully amazing that Jesus tells us that after giving us
the eucharist, there was actually nothing else that God could do to show his infinite love for us.
We need to start thinking about that. And just as my incarnation, life and passion on the cross
receive love, praise, thanksgiving and imitation, my sacramental life receives from man an ecstatic
love. This is the adoration that we give to the Lord and the contemplation. My sacramental life
receives from man an ecstatic love, a love of dissolving oneself in me, a love of perfect
consummation. And as the soul is consumed in my very sacramental life, she can say that she performs
before the divinity, the same officers that I perform continuously before God for love of men.
And this consummation will make this soul overflow with eternal life. We really need to just read that
message over and over again in order to somehow take it on board. So I'll give you another short
one and then we'll stop for now. July the 7th, 1902, the continuous humiliation with Christ
will give rise to everlasting exaltation with Christ. So this morning since Blessed Jesus was
not coming, I felt all confused and humiliated. Then after I struggled very much, he made himself
seen for just a little telling me, Louisa, always humiliated with Christ. And I pleased and yearning
to be humiliated with Christ said always Lord. And he repeated and the always of the humiliation
with Christ will give rise to the always of the exaltation with Christ. So I understood that as
many humiliations that the soul undergoes with Christ and for love of him, if they are continuous,
so many times will the Lord exalt her. And he will make this exaltation continuous before the whole
celestial court, before men, and finally even before the demons themselves. Wonderful. I want
to leave that there for just for now.